foreign
this is a new client who came in off of
my waitlist wanting to get a full
rainbow transformation the first thing I
did was get rid of that excess length
and the previously lightened hair
because we were going to be cutting it
shorter at the end anyway
[Music]
we decided on doing a Fletcher inspired
sectioning underneath where it's thicker
on one side and thinner on the other
where we were going to be putting the
rainbow prism and then on the top
section we did a lavender color with
rainbows in between we also decided to
add rainbows right around the face like
a money piece so that it would pull
everything together when you're looking
at her from the front the transformation
took me seven hours in total
thank you
[Music]